Do your genes tell a story?
All 20,000 of them wrapped up in 23 pairs of chromosomes can guide a future and shape a destiny.
However, that's only part of your biography.
It is what you do with your genes that make the difference.
If you know your genes, it's like owning your map.
There are roads to different places.
Some roads are highways and others are gravel.
Some places are where you want to go.
Others are what you want to avoid.
The more you understand the map, the better choices you can make to arrive at the destination you desire.
Dr. Conner's complete genetic report is like a GPS that helps guide you, so you become the driver on the highways of life.
You choose the destination and direction.
Your road of life will present many choices.
Knowing the path less traveled by will make all the difference.
Your genes are the words.
You write the story.
Let Dr. Conner's help you write your autobiography.
Go to www.conner's clinic.com or call 651-739-1248 to learn more.